We reload the map.
It looks like the circles are placed in reasonably right locations.
We can see the South Korea and Japan World Cup, the South Africa World Cup.
A number of World Cups in various countries in South America,
a number of World Cups in various European countries and
then two World Cups in Mexico and one in the U.S.
and good news that no circles were plotted in the middle of the ocean.
Means that the center pixels that we calculated, are approximately correct and
what's left to do, is to properly scale the circles, so
that they correctly represent the attendance.
So, rather than using a constant value, set the attribute r,
while passing an accessor function, which in this case will set to
the aggregate attendance, for a given year of the world cup.
Going back to our map and reloading the page, however, we
can see that something has gone very, very wrong and the whole screen is black.
Can you figure out what went wrong with the visualization,
when we tried to set the radius of our circles?